if we truly have an actual open debate
pretty much ninety percent of everything
they believe is gonna is gonna be
obliterated yup that's why they don't
want to come on the show yep and every
every polite invite gets turned down we
will pay for your travel we will fly you
first class we will get a car waiting
for you with a guy holding up a sign
with your name on it we'll bring you out
there will be a filet mignon medium rare
oscar style right on this table it was
great service and you can say whatever
you want and they're like no wait okay
while insulting Tim across from it I'm
saying for leftists we gotta we gotta
pull out of the stocks well that's red
carpet come on down and they're like no
and then you get the grifter ones who
are like just willing to lie cheat and
steal for fame and they're like oh come
on it's like not you yeah and we know
what your game is I'm talking about the
actual personalities we're talking about
leftist politics and policies